Silence ça pousse les villas du maille
sortent de terre la première pierre
vient d'être posée ce mardi TR îos de 32
logements au sein de la zag Villarois le
programme fait partie d'un ensemble plus
vaste comprenant 220 logements nous
aurons aussi des programmes en accession
aidé y compris d'ailleurs en location
vente c'est des locataires qui pourront
devenir propriétaires et là ce sont
évidemment avec des critères et pour
l'aiguill en courtois l'opération est
labellisé Bâtiments Basse Consommation
et Habitat et Environnement devanant
ainsi la réglementation à venir sur les
matériaux en fait les façades en fait on
a une partie qui est habillée en
pierre l'autre partie en fait des
bâtiments en fait c'est une isolation
par l'extérieur avec un enduit et donc
l'idée en fait c'est d'avoir un bâtiment
très bien isolé la livraison est prévue
pour le dernier trimestre 2013 les 32
logements ont déjà tous trouvé acquéreur
au prix de 3600
m car un peu moins que le prix moyen
pratiqué dans le département qui
avoisine les 3900
€